COLT MCANLIS: In this episode
of "Cloud Performance Atlas,"
we help some happy honey-makers
fix their regional performance.
Want to see what all
the buzz is about?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The Bee Party is a
conservation-focused
organization which provides
data scientists, researchers,
farmers, and
agricultural companies
with the data they need to help
preserve the mighty honeybee.
Since their efforts had
now achieved critical mass,
their technology team
started getting complaints
from their global regions
that data access was slower
than desired.
Now, regional performance
is a common problem.
Because, you know, physics.
But if the network has
been set up properly,
this shouldn't "bee" an issue.
Anyhow, when we
talk about latency,
one of the most important
things we must remember
is that it's a
function of physics.
Now, the speed of light
traveling through a fiber
optic cable takes roughly
about 10 milliseconds
to travel about
1,000 kilometers.
So the further away you
are from your destination,
the higher your latency.
This is why Google
Cloud Platform
places new data centers
in various regions
around the world.
The goal is to find the sweet
spot between distance, latency,
and disaster tolerance.
To get a sense of
this behavior, I
set up an instance
in each GCP region
and pinged them from
my desktop machine
here in Austin, Texas
about 100 times.
As expected, the farther
away the instance
is, the worse the latency to it.
But I'm just one data point.
Probably more important
is to understand
the performance
between each region,
which is
straightforward to test.
We already had the instances
set up in each region,
so we just had to measure the
throughput from one location
to each other location.
From this graph,
we can clearly see
that the Europe West to
Asia East and the US West
to Asia East are some of the
lowest throughput connections,
while any of the US
to US connections
have some of the
highest throughput.
Now that we have an
understanding of baseline
performance, let's
try to figure out
how the bee party is set up.
And as always, I start
with logging data.
Looking at the user
agents fields of our logs,
we can see that most
of their requests
are coming from
desktop connections.
This is good, since
it means we're not
getting skewed results due to
2G or 3G connection speeds.
No worries there.
When we drill in some, we
can see the slower traces,
we can start to see
a consistent pattern.
Most of the highest
density and latency traces
are coming from
areas in Japan this
threw up a big red
flag for me, since I
knew that the bee party was a
nonprofit company stationed out
of Europe.
A quick phone call with
their CTO confirmed this.
The Bee Party is
based out of Germany,
and they deploy all
their GCE instances
in the European region.
Well of course,
there's our problem.
The majority of their clients
are coming from Japan,
while the instances are
only deployed in Europe.
From our previous graph, we
saw that this was already
one of the lowest
performing connections.
The solution for The Bee
Party was quite clear.
They needed to play instances
of their VMs in regions
closer to their primary
user base, which requires
us to change two things.
Firstly is creating a new
instance group for the Asia
East region so the
researchers in Japan
can be connecting to the
closest instances possible.
Secondly is putting together
a global HTTP load balancer
whose job is to route
requests to the nearest
healthy instances.
This way, clients in
Japan get their packets
routed to the Asia
East cluster rather
than having to go all
the way to Europe for it.
Oh, by the way, did
you know that Japan
has one of the most awesome
type of honeybee on the planet?
The Japanese honeybee
has a unique defense
for fighting predatory wasps.
They swarm it, hug it, and
start vibrating fast enough
to raise the internal
heat of their bee ball
to 117 degree Fahrenheit,
killing the hornet,
but leaving the bees unharmed,
which you've got to admit
is pretty cool.
Anyhow, if you'd like to improve
the performance of your cloud
applications, don't
forget to check out
the rest of our "Cloud
Performance Atlas" content.
And when it comes to the
environment, remember,
every honeybee counts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]